>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> We have a wonderful
program planned for you today,
and we're doing it with one
of our long-time partners,
Everybody Wins DC,
a program I've known
about for a long time
and really admire.
This is part of their
career literacy series
in which they select
a partner for an event
and provide everyone
with a free book.
I want to take just a moment
to thank our co-sponsor,
Everybody Wins, and I'd also
like to introduce their new
executive director, Molly Teas.
Molly.
[ Applause ]
Welcome, and thank you, and I know
you're going to take Everybody Wins
to new heights, so we're
just delighted you're here.
Thanks to Everybody Wins.
You all are going to get a copy
of the national book
award-wining "March" the third.
I hope I get one too.
It's a graphic novel by Congressman
Lewis and his digital director
and policy advisor, Andrew Aydin.
So together they have
written a fascinating account
of the civil rights marches
in Selma, Alabama, in 1965.
Also with us today, and
this is a real treat,
from WAMU Radio is long-time
talk show host Kojo Nnamdi.
We're very lucky-- yes.
[ Applause ]
We're very fortunate to have
him here today and taking time
out of his very busy schedule, and
he is going to moderate our question
and answer period, which is when
you all will have the opportunity
to ask questions.
The program is being
recorded, so please wait
for a microphone before
you ask your question.
And now I want to go off
script for just two minutes.
The first thing is, I just saw
the wonderful PBS documentary
about the life of Congressman Lewis.
It's really unbelievable, and
one of the things that he talks
about in the documentary is the
great civil rights icon, Rosa Parks.
And I want you to know that we,
the Library of Congress
has the Rosa Parks papers
in our collection, and
they're all online.
You can go to our website,
LOC.gov, and you can get all of,
you can see all of Rosa Parks'
papers, and they are amazing.
The second thing I want to say
is that I was in Orlando in June
when Congressman Lewis spoke at a
memorial service for the victims
of those killed in the nightclub
in Orlando, and Congressman Lewis,
I have to tell you, it was one
of the most inspiring speeches I
have ever heard, and I just want
to thank you for all you do,
and I'm just really grateful.
So with that, I'm going
to turn it over to Kojo,
and have a wonderful time,
and thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Kojo Nnamdi: Thank
you all for coming.
The third installment in
the March trilogy written
by Congressman John Lewis and Andrew
Aydin, illustrated by Nate Powell,
has won a lot of awards--
the National Book Award for
Young People's Literature,
the Coretta Scott King Book Award,
the Michael L. Printz Award,
the Robert F. Sibert
Informational Book Award,
the Young Adult Library Services
Association Award for Excellence
in Nonfiction, the
Walter Dean Myers Award
for Outstanding Children's
Literature Young Adult Category--
and that's just to name a few.
It's a best seller that has helped
to further break down the barriers
between graphic novels or comics
and powerful work of nonfiction,
and so I am delighted to
talk with the Congressman
and Andrew Aydin today
to talk about it.
Could you please welcome
Congressman John Lewis.
[ Applause ]
And Andrew Aydin.
Congressman Lewis,
I'll start with you.
You've been tireless in your work
not just on this book but in talking
about it with students, with
librarians, and journalists,
and you gave a very moving speech
in accepting the National
Book Award late last year.
What does the recognition this
work has received mean to you?
>> Rep. John Lewis: Well thank you.
First of all, Kojo, it's
good to see you brother.
Always good to see you.
And thank you for all the good
and great things that
you continue to do.
It's good to be here at the
Library of Congress, good to see all
of you beautiful, handsome
young people.
You look so wonderful.
You look so smart.
When I go and speak about this book,
reread the book, turn the pages,
and see certain drawings
and images, it takes me back
to another part of my life.
You know from reading "March" book
one, book two, and book three,
I grew up in rural Alabama,
50 miles from Montgomery,
outside of a little
place called Troy.
So [inaudible] received
[inaudible] along with Andrew Aydin
and Nate Powell, it was too much.
We stood together, and I
was, I was lost for words.
It took me back to rural Alabama
in 1956 when I was 16 years old
with some of my brothers
and sisters and cousins.
We went to a little library
to try to get a library card,
trying to check out some books,
and we were told by the librarian
that the library was for
whites only and not for colors.
I didn't go back to that library
for many, many years later,
but this time I'm in the
Congress for a book signing.
So hundreds of blacks and
white citizens showed up,
and after the book signing,
after we had some refreshment,
they gave me a library card.
And to work with Andrew, who
is so gifted and so smart,
and Nate Powell, it's
been a work of love.
And to see young people
standing in line to get the book,
to get the book signed, and to take
a seat in the middle of the floor
at a table, a desk, and read
the book, and as I travel
around America, different places,
people come up with the book,
said I'm buying this book for
my son or my brother, my nieces,
my nephews, so I think
it's a good thing.
We all should read.
Books are powerful.
They can take us places
that we dare to go.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: I'm glad you
finally got your library card.
>> Rep. John Lewis: Yes.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: Before we get
to the third book in the series,
let's talk a little bit about
why this project took the shape
that it did as a graphic novel.
Comics actually have some
ties to civil rights movement.
When did you first
encounter a comic that spoke
to the civil rights movement?
>> In late 1957 or
either early 1958,
I remember reading a comic book
called Martin Luther King Jr.
and the Montgomery Story.
It sold for ten cents, and Andrew
would tell you through his research,
he discovered that Dr.
King helped edit this book.
This book became like a road map
for those of us that got involved
in the American civil
rights movement.
It told the story of Montgomery.
It spoke about the way of peace,
the way of love, the philosophy
for nonviolence, how people
organize, how people walked,
shared rides in cars, church
buses, [inaudible] rides,
segregated buses in Montgomery.
In Montgomery during the '50's,
black and white people couldn't
be seated together on a city bus.
Even here in Washington, DC, in
1961 during the freedom rise,
black people and white people
couldn't be seated together leaving
Washington to travel through
Virginia or North Carolina
or South Carolina or
Georgia, Alabama, Mississippi.
So public transportation, whether
the train or buses, had been a means
of carrying the story in the way
of the civil rights movement.
[Inaudible] those signs that said
white waiting, colored waiting,
white men, colored men,
white women, colored women.
And I say to young
people all the time,
growing up today you won't
see those signs on a bus
or on a train or a waiting room.
The only place that you'll see
those signs today will be in a book,
in a museum, or on a video.
They're gone, and it's my hope
they will never, ever return.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: Andrew
Aydin, despite the fact
that the Congressman encountered
that graphic novel of comic
about Dr. King when he
was just 17 years old,
you still had a little trouble
convincing your colleagues
and even the Congressman
himself to write a graphic novel.
Why did you think this was the
right format for this project?
>> Andrew Aydin: I
grew up in Atlanta.
The Congressman has
been my Congressman
since I was three years old.
I went to Atlanta Public
Schools, and I heard the story
of the Civil Rights Movement
over and over and over again.
I heard it in documentaries.
I heard it in books.
I heard people tell the stories.
But to me, I'd grown
up reading comics.
It was sort of my salvations,
my refuge, right.
My father left when I was
four or five years old,
and it was sort of where I turned.
I wanted stories of
heroes who wanted justice
because it was the
right thing to do.
And that summer [loud tone
noise], should I bebop that?
[laughter] That summer
of the campaign in 2008,
Barack Obama was sweeping
through the democratic primaries,
people in politics were
fundamentally reevaluating the way
in which they communicate with
young people but with everyone,
whether it's the internet,
the visual literacy that comes
with that, or simply just
how you talk to people,
like what we're willing
to talk about.
And so as it came down
to the internet campaign
and the Congressman tells
me about Martin Luther King
and the Montgomery story, I
mean these were two things
that were incredibly
important in my life.
Here I'd spent the whole summer
watching John Lewis tell these
stories that I had never
heard growing up in Atlanta.
The story of SNCC, the
story of the young people,
which was so much different than
the story I had always been told,
and at the same time the
Congressman was telling me
that he read a comic book when he
thought about joining the movement.
I mean, the 24-year-old nerd
just kind of exploded, you know.
And it felt like it was
okay to be me, right.
Like oh, maybe it wasn't so weird
for me to like comics after all.
Maybe it was all the other people
who put them down who were wrong.
And so when I try to think, you
know, there should be a comic book
about John Lewis' life,
it was in a sense
to show everyone what I
had just seen that summer,
what I had witnessed first-hand.
And hearing John Lewis tell the
story, seeing him acted out,
seeing him in front of you, that
was a big part of it for me,
and so trying to find a way to
capture that experience and put it
down on paper, words alone
could not do it the justice
that it needed, so--
>> Kojo Nnamdi: What do you make
of the shift and the perception
of graphic novels that the
"March" trilogy has been a part
of and maybe a leader in?
>> Andrew Aydin: I think we broke
the publishing system a little bit,
and I think in a sense "March" is
putting it back together stronger
than it was before.
I don't think we set
out to do that, per se.
We set out to tell
John Lewis' story.
We set out to tell it in a way
that would reach more people
than had ever been
reached by this story.
But the result is, is I
think comics are coming
of age because of the Internet.
Because like all you all,
you all are digital natives.
You grew up on the Internet.
You communicate through
memes, right?
Like they don't admit it, but like
you have whole conversations with,
you know, success kid,
and everything else.
And so, yeah, yeah,
somebody's [inaudible] okay.
And so for this generation,
comics is there natural language.
It is graphic narrative.
It is, it is sequential
story telling.
It is just simply how this
generation speaks to each other.
And so it was only a matter of time,
I think what we're most fortunate
about is that it was John Lewis'
story that broke down that barrier.
It was a little bit ahead of its
time, and so it was right there
when it needed to be there
as opposed to, you know,
we could all be celebrating the, I
don't know, the great puppy wars,
or something, you know, that really
wouldn't resonate with us the way
that John Lewis' story
does and that needs
to be immortalized the way
John Lewis' story does.
And so I think it was a combination
of being just a little bit ahead
of our time and being at the right
place for this generation to be able
to embrace it because
it's their language.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: Congressman Lewis,
did it take a lot of convincing
to get you involved in
writing what [inaudible].
>> Rep. John Lewis: Well, Andrew,
I think probably would say,
well, it took a little time.
But he didn't give up, you know.
He just said, Congressman,
you should write a comic book.
I said, oh, maybe.
He came back again, and I don't
know how many times he came back.
>> Andrew Aydin: Who's counting?
>> Rep. John Lewis:
We didn't keep count.
[laughter] And I said, I
finally said something like, yes,
if you do it with me,
and the rest is history.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: Indeed,
a remarkable history.
This trilogy begins as
a reflection on the eve
of President Obama's inauguration,
a reflection on the work you did
during the civil rights movement,
and it ends more to come here.
Are we in a period
now where we're seeing
that there's more work
to be done here?
>> Rep. John Lewis:
Well, I think we are.
I just left an unbelievable meeting
when I go enter in on a discussion
about it, but I think in America
today right now people are saying
where are we going as a
nation and as a people?
Are we going backward?
Are we going to stand still?
Or are we going to go forward?
I think [inaudible] tell us
all that we've come a distance,
we've made a lot of progress,
but there are forces that want
to slow us down or take us back,
and we would like for people
to be hopeful, to be optimistic, and
to understand that we're one people,
that it doesn't matter whether
we're black or white, Latino,
Asian American, or Native American.
We all live in the same house.
Not just American house,
but the world house.
There was a man by the name of
A. Philip Randolph that we speak
about because he was the man
who called together the march
on Washington, and he used
to say from time to time,
maybe our foremothers and
our forefathers all came
to this great land
in different ships,
but we're all in the same boat now.
We have to look out for each
other and care for each other.
And Dr. King said on one occasion,
and he said it so beautifully,
that we must learn to live together
as one family, as one people.
If not, [inaudible] as fools.
And I think this is message that
we try to convey in "March."
That it's better to love.
It's better to abide by the
principles and the philosophy
of nonviolence and never hate for
hate is too heavy a burden to bear.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: A. Philip Randolph
was the head of the Brotherhood
of Sleeping Car Porters, and
as Congressman Lewis said,
he called the march on
Washington together in 1963.
Andrew Aydin, as you were
going through this process
with the Congressman, it gave you
not only a perspective on his life,
but did it give you an
additional perspective on history
that allows you to better
interpret the present?
>> Andrew Aydin: Absolutely.
When we first debuted book one,
we went to San Diego Comic-Con,
which is more of my people, right.
And so we'd start off, he'd give
a little speech about, you know,
this is what my book
is about, right?
And I asked, I said, have any of you
guys watched Battlestar Galactica?
You know, it's Comic-Con, so
every hand in the room went up.
And I said well then, you
know, you'll remember all
of this has happened before, and
all of this will happen again.
And this was in 2013.
This was before Ferguson.
This was before Eric Garner.
This was before the election.
This was at a time when I think
people thought it was going
to be quiet for a while.
But the more you understand about
John Lewis' story and how much
of our politics today are a
direct result from forces trying
to oppose the progress that
he made, the more it seems
like an inevitable
conflict was coming.
And at the same time, I hope
we conveyed the optimism
that the activists today need,
that the young people they need.
I'll often ask the question or pose
it, you know, we have SCLC still.
We have the NAACP still.
We have the Urban League still.
What we don't have today
is a student nonviolent
coordinating committee.
We don't have an organization
of young people dedicate
to direct action that
is completely staffed
and organized and run
by young people.
And so when you look
at it in that sort
of context today, history
is your guide.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: What
stood out to you
that maybe you didn't
know about before.
I'll tell you what stood
out to me when I read this.
I am, as many people know, from
the Caribbean, and when I read
about an attorney who
represented the Congressman early
in his [inaudible] named Alexander
Looby, Alexander Looby it turned
out was from Antigua, West India.
That was like, whoa, I'm much
more interested in this story now.
[laughter] Did you have those
kinds of experiences, Andrew?
Who stood out to you that maybe
you did not know about beforehand.
>> Andrew Aydin: There
was just so many of them.
I mean in Nashville I had no idea
about Will Campbell
or Kelly Miller Smith.
Many of the people that
played such a formative role.
I mean Jim Lawson right off the bat.
I mean I'd heard about him and the
Congressman has spoken about him,
but the extent of Reverend Lawson's
role internet Civil Rights Movement
in and of itself have
sort of been lost,
and I hope we've resurrected
his contribution
because it is so powerful.
I mean he may be the
most influential figure
on the movement behind
Martin Luther King.
But it was things like
Bayard Rustin, and you know,
I didn't know Strom Thurmond had
outed him as a gay man on the floor
of the United States Senate.
And when you see people do
something similar to that today,
it's hard not to feel
as if they walk
in that legacy of Strom Thurmond.
Or in that vein, I mean I came to
really appreciate the relationship
between A. Philip Randolph
and Bayard Rustin.
You know, Randolph actually
threatened the first march
on Washington in 1941, and in effect
made FDR blink and desegregate parts
of the military industrial complex.
And so when it was
coming down to the end
of book two's research period,
I read an interview from Rustin
and asked him, what was the most
meaningful moment of your life,
and he said, you know, there was
this moment at the end of the march
on Washington and he
came back to the office
and he saw A. Philip
Randolph looking at his sign,
and he started teasing him.
Hey boss, there's not
a piece of trash
or garbage that's completely
cleaned up, you know,
thinking it was a celebratory
moment, and Randolph turned around,
and he had tears streaming
down his face.
And he just grabbed
Rustin and gave him a hug
and said, thank you Bayard.
And he said that was the most
meaningful moment of his life,
and here it was buried in an
interview and a textbook somewhere.
And I thought, what a privilege to
be able to offer our own thank you
to him for his contribution, a thank
you that was long, long overdue.
It's things like that.
>> Rep. John Lewis: I should
say to the young people here,
when you pass through Union Station
there's a bus, A. Philip Randolph,
who was this unbelievable man who
was born in Jacksonville, Florida,
moved to New York City and became a
champ in human rights, civil rights,
labor rights, and he had
the ability to organize
and move people [inaudible]
and just stated Presidents.
It was A. Philip Randolph
that called that meeting
with President Kennedy when
we had the first meeting
to discuss the possibility
of a march on Washington.
And you speak about Z.
Alexander Looby, amazing lawyer,
just an unbelievable human being,
and we were sitting in and marching
as students, his home was
bombed early one morning.
It destroyed part of his house.
His wife was knocked out of her bed.
It was near Fisk University,
Meharry Medical School,
[inaudible] bomb his home, the
Klan tried to kill him and destroy.
We made a decision to march
when we heard about it,
like 6:30 in the morning.
We sent a telegram to the mayor
of the city in Nashville saying
in effect, Mr. Mayor,
meet us on the steps
of city hall at noon, and by noon--
>> Andrew Aydin: High
noon, high noon.
Because you've been
watching westerns.
>> Rep. John Lewis:
That's right, high noon.
That's right, Andrew.
High noon.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: My favorite western.
>> Rep. John Lewis: And we
had thousands and thousands
of young people, black and
white, high school students,
colored students, parents,
teachers, college professors,
and the mayor said, yes,
I favor desegregation
at the lunch counters
and in the restaurants.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: There's so much
history packed into this trilogy,
so many names that jump out at
you, Al Lowenstein, Ella Baker,
James Forman, Bob Moses,
Fanny Lou Hamer.
Talk a little bit about
any one of those people,
who our students here
might not know of.
>> Rep. John Lewis: Andrew?
>> Andrew Aydin: I'd go with
Ella Baker right off the bat.
I mean, she was the mother of
the movement and is so pivotal
in a way that's not fully understood
today, and I hope we conveyed
that as much as possible because
she's one of those characters
that lives with you
through all of the books.
She was there at the founding
of SNCC, and she was there
at the founding of the Mississippi
Freedom Democratic Party.
She was a keynote speaker at
their political convention
in August of 1964.
She was so important, and I
think one of the great tragedies
of the history that's
been told thus far is
that women's roles during the
movement have been marginalized,
and I think for us it was so
important to correct that,
to show women like Fanny Lou Hamer
and Ella Baker and Diane Nash
and Genevieve Hughes and everybody
else who participated in one way
or the other because they
so often were the ones
who did the nitty gritty.
They didn't push to be
the one in the photograph.
They pushed to be the
one who did the work,
who achieved the hardest part.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: Fascinating.
When I first came to Washington
among my mentors were people
who worked with the Congressman
[inaudible], and so I knew all
of those names but didn't
quite know the details
of the history of those individuals.
The trilogy helped me
to understand that,
why my friends revered Ella Baker
and why they revered Bob Moses
so much during those time.
But you two worked with illustrated
Nate Powell on this series,
and his images are vivid,
sometimes difficult to look at.
Congressman Lewis, was it difficult
for you to think back to those times
and see them depicted in black and
white on the pages of the series?
>> Rep. John Lewis: Well, yes,
and it's still difficult today
when I pick up this book, this
is book three, but book one
and book two, and see
some of the images.
Sometimes I tear up.
Sometimes I cry.
There is an illustration in
this book depicting me marching,
and I love it because I
guess there's young people,
and I'm not that young anymore,
but I did look so young, so young.
I had all of my hair, and
I was a few pounds lighter,
and to see me with my backpack.
Back in 1965 we were attempting
to march from Selma to Montgomery,
I thought we was going to
be arrested and go to jail.
So I bought a backpack from an
army surplus store, of all places,
and I wanted to have something to
read while I was in jail, so I had,
I thought I was going to really
go to jail, so I had two books.
I wanted to have something to eat,
I had an apple and I had an orange.
Since I was going to be in jail
with my friends and my colleagues,
I wanted to be able
to brush my teeth,
so I had toothpaste
and a toothbrush.
And when you look at book three
and turn the page, Andrew you know,
I've told you this, I love
that image of this strong,
young John Lewis getting ready
to walk across that bridge.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: With
an apple and an orange.
You know, reading these books,
one discovers that you often went
against the grain of what others in
the movement were doing or wanted
to do, skipping the signing
ceremony for the civil rights act,
keeping the protests going when the
so-called big fix asked you not to,
going ahead with the
aforementioned Selma
to Montgomery march [inaudible]
and SNCC were against it.
And you talk a lot about this idea
of good trouble, about standing
up for what's right even when it's
not popular, when it's not easy.
Where did you get that
strength from?
What do you want these
young people to know
about the notion of good trouble?
Maybe just as impatient, how
do you know you're getting
into the good kind of
trouble and not the bad kind?
>> Rep. John Lewis:
Well, it's very simple.
When I was growing up and would
visit the little town of Troy,
visit Montgomery, Troy's about
ten miles from where I grew up.
You go downtown Troy, you see the
signs that say white and colored,
to go to a movie on
a Saturday afternoon,
all of us little black children
had to go upstairs to the balcony,
and all of the white
children went downstairs.
I would come home and
ask my mother, my father,
my grandparents, why, why?
And they would say, that's the
way it is, don't get in trouble.
But I heard of Rosa Parks
when I was 15 years old,
and I met Rosa Parks when I was 17.
I heard of Dr. King
when I was 15 years old,
and I met him when I was 18.
It changed my mind, and
so I was inspired to get
in what I call good
trouble, necessary trouble,
and I've been getting
in trouble ever since.
It's very simple to me, when you
see something that is not right,
not fair, not just,
you have an obligation
to say something, to do something.
We cannot afford to be silent.
Because if we're silent, if you
think you like being mistreated,
you have to resist, and
say that's not right,
that's not fair, that's not just.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: For the students in
this room, who live in the District
of Columbia, a city that has
no voting license in Congress,
residents of whom many would
like to see this as a state,
these young people may one
day decide to be active now
and even more so when they reach
voting age, what do you make
of these very fundamental questions
that persist around the issue
of voting rights, not only in
the district in a very vivid way,
but in a lot of jurisdictions in
the United States when it comes
to adequate photo representation.
The Voting Rights Act
was passed in 1965?
[inaudible] is a resident
of the District of Columbia.
>> Andrew Aydin: Yeah,
I mean as a DC resident,
I think it's long overdue that we
had full representation in Congress.
I don't understand why we can
live in this city and pay taxes
in this city and, you know, it
seems so often that the opponents
of voting rights are
also the same people
who declare their rights based
on how much taxes they pay.
And yet, here we are in the
district, and we pay quite a bit,
and we don't have full
representation.
I think for young people
in particular it's a tremendous
opportunity for civil disobedience.
I'm just saying, don't
tell your teachers.
[laughter] But I think we
have to acknowledge the fact
that voting rights are under
attack all across the country,
whether it is fictitious
claims that millions
of people are voting
illegally, which they're not.
Let's just say it, they're not.
Or the attempts to make it
harder and more difficult
for people to register and vote.
Full disclosure, I worked on one
of the campaigns in November,
and I was shocked to find
that only one party has voter
protection teams.
The other party doesn't need them,
their voters don't have any trouble,
and that was profound to me, that
we could create a system that was
so lopsided in its advantages.
But when you work for John
Lewis, it's much more than that.
It is about a fundamental
American belief
that we are all created
equal, and in that belief
that we are all given the
right to vote as participants
in the American democracy, and
when you work against that,
you work against what makes America
strong and what has brought America
to the forefront of global
power, and it makes America weak.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: For those of you
in this room who may be thinking
of what your rights are, and
you should be, you should know
that sitting in this room is the
Attorney General of the District
of Columbia, so when this
is over, you should go over
and have a chat with him.
[Inaudible], would you
raise your hand, please.
Let us know who you are.
[ Laughter ]
Congressman Lewis, today we see a
lot of energy, a lot of young people
who would like to effect change,
but there have been those who say
that these current movements lack
direction and they lack leadership
and cohesion, some of the
things that people said
about SNCC back in
1960, as I recall.
What is your hope for
what these books
and for what you can teach
this younger generation
of activists and protesters.
>> Rep. John Lewis:
Well, it is my hope
that these books would
inspire another generation
but the special young people,
the young, to learn the lessons
of the movement, what we
did and what we tried to do
and how we succeeded, and to
be hopeful, to be optimistic,
and to never give up, but
hold onto your dreams.
It [inaudible] down to
these books being a roadmap,
a blue print, to get in the way.
During the '60's, I got
arrested a few times, 40 times,
and since I've been in
Congress another five times.
My last arrest, this
young man had to--
I left my money some place,
so he had to lend me--
>> Andrew Aydin: I
spotted you a few dollars.
>> Rep. John Lewis: A few dollars,
to get out of, to be released.
The last arrest took place
a short distance from here,
over on the Capitol
grounds, where 200 people,
eight members of Congress, who
were trying to get the Speaker
of the House to bring forth
a comprehensive immigration
reform deal.
We had brought the bill
to the floor of the House,
almost every single member on our
side of the aisle would have voted
for it, and we would have picked up
enough members from the other side,
and we would have passed it,
and President Barack Obama
would have signed it into law.
It doesn't make sense for us
to have millions of people,
especially young people,
children, living in fear
that something is going
to happen to them
or to their parents or grandparents.
We should set people on
the path of citizenship.
When the Pope came and spoke to a
[inaudible] session of the Congress,
he said we all were immigrants,
we all come from some other place,
and that will probably be the
great debate in the days to come.
And none of us are really
free, and all of us are free.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: Now it's time
for you to ask questions.
I know there are those of
you who have read, one, two,
or all books in the trilogy,
so now is the time for you
to raise your hand, because if you
don't, I will just keep talking more
and more and more and
probably bore you to tears.
Anyone, oh, there's a
hand raised up front here.
[ Background Noise ]
>> I didn't do--
>> Kojo Nnamdi: Stand up
please so we can see you.
>> I didn't do research on you
but was you born like around
when Martin Luther King was
born, or is he older than you?
>> Kojo Nnamdi: When
were you born in relation
to when Dr. King was born.
>> Rep. John Lewis: Well,
Dr. Martin Luther King, Jr.,
was born in 1929, and
I was born in 1940.
So in a sense, he was
like a big brother.
[ Background Noise ]
I met him when I was 18 years old.
He changed my life.
Andrew would tell you that he
called me the boy from Troy.
Probably in reading "March" some of
you read when I was a little boy,
growing up on that farm,
I wanted to be a minister,
and we used to raise chickens.
And with the help of my
brothers and sisters and cousins,
we would gather all of our chickens
together in the chicken yard,
like you are gathered right here
in this room, and my brothers
and sisters and cousins would like
[inaudible] around the chicken yard,
and I would start speaking or
preaching, and when I looked back,
some of these chickens
would bow their heads.
Some of the chickens
would shake their heads.
They never quite said Amen.
[laughter] But I'm convinced that
some of those chickens tended
to listen to me much better than
some of my colleagues listen
to me today in the Congress.
And some of those chickens were
just a little more productive,
at least they produced eggs,
and Drew didn't want
me to tell that story.
>> Andrew Aydin: Well, we had to
leave those lines out of the book.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: I found that to be
one of the more fascinating parts
of the book, his relationship with
the chickens, when he was talking
to the chickens and the chickens,
he knew the chickens individually--
>> Andrew Aydin: By name, yeah.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: And after a
point he didn't like the fact
that the chickens had to be
killed in order to be eaten.
>> Rep. John Lewis: And
I boycotted the meals.
I didn't like the fact that
my mother and father wanted
to have some of those
chickens for a meal,
and I got to know these chickens.
I told them to be quiet, not
to make noise, not to fight,
for them to love each other.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: Any other
hands raised with questions?
Right down here.
[ Background Noise ]
>> So, actually last year our school
went on a field trip to a bunch
of junior, or rangers' memorials
all around, all around the south,
and so one of the places that
we actually went to was Selma,
and we walked across the bridge that
you walked across on, across on,
so could you tell us what
some of your experiences were
when you crossed that bridge?
>> Kojo Nnamdi: When
you crossed the bridge.
>> Rep. John Lewis: Yeah, in Selma,
Alabama, like so many other parts
of the south, people of color
could not register to vote
because of the color of their skin.
There were African American lawyers,
doctors, teachers, housewives,
and farmers were told that they
could not read or write well enough.
Sometimes people were asked to
count the number of bubbles in a bar
of soap, the number of
jelly beans in a jar.
One day more than 300 public school
teachers left school, lined up,
and went down to the court house
to receive a copy of the test.
The stood in line.
The registrar closed the office,
and they were denied the
right to register to vote.
And a few days later as you
saw maybe in the movie Selma,
a group of people marched, it
was a protest, in the home town
of Mrs. Martin Luther King,
Jr., Loretta Scott King,
and one protester was shot and later
died at the local hospital in Selma.
Because of what happened to
him, we made a decision to march
from Selma to Montgomery.
Six hundred of us in twos, orderly,
peaceful, no one saying a word.
The night before the march, the
local sheriff, he was a mean man,
really just mean, who wore a button
on his left lapel that said never.
He carried an electric cow prodder,
and he didn't use it on cows.
He used it on people.
He would push people.
He would beat people for exercising
their constitutional right.
So on that bridge that Sunday,
we got to the highest point
on the Edmund Pettus bridge,
down below we saw a sea of blue,
Alabama state troopers,
and we continued to walk.
We came within hearing distance.
A man spoke up and said
I'm Major John Cloud
of the Alabama state troopers.
This is an unlawful march.
It will not be allowed to continue.
I give you three minutes
to disperse and return
to your homes or to your church.
And a young man walking
beside me, one of the leaders
from Dr. King's organization by the
name of Jose Williams, said, Major,
give us a moment to kneel and pray.
And the Major said,
troopers advance.
I said Major, may I have a word?
He said, there will be no word.
They came, beating us with night
sticks, trampling with horses,
releasing their tear gas.
I was hit in the head by a state
trooper with a night stick.
My legs went from under me.
I thought I saw death.
I thought I was going
to die on that bridge.
I thought it was the
last nonviolent protest.
And all these many years later,
I don't recall how I made it back
across that bridge to the little
church that we had left from,
but I remember being in the
church and someone asked me
to say something, and I
stood up and said something
like I don't understand it how
President Johnson can send troops
to Vietnam but cannot send troops
to Selma, Alabama, to protect people
who only desire to register to vote.
The next thing I knew, with 16
other people, we was transferred
to a little hospital where a
group of nuns took care of us.
And last, just before the
election, late last October,
I went to Rochester, New York, to
campaign for one of my colleagues
in New York, they took me
to the mother house there,
some of the nuns are retired, and
I saw this stained-glass window
that had been in this hospital,
it's now in Rochester, New York,
and some of the nuns that
took care me, they was there.
They remembered me, and they started
saying John, John, good to see you.
And we all cried together.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: Andrew Aydin, one
of the things that struck me most
in reading this trilogy
was how John Lewis
and the other protesters trained
themselves to respond nonviolently
to the most violent
attacks by both civilians
and law enforcement officers.
You are even younger than I am.
How did that strike you?
>> Andrew Aydin: It felt like the
most important factor we could
possibly convey.
I think many of us understand the
broad strokes of civil disobedience.
Maybe we have read Thoreau or
Emerson or something like that,
but really understanding the
nitty gritty, the details,
the perseverance, and
the self-control it takes
to be a successful protestor
or a successful activist
using civil disobedience.
And over and over and over
again as you read these texts,
as you read the accounts,
the defining characteristic
of the most successful
protest is how orderly
and how disciplined they were.
And so for us, showing
that discipline is part
of the visual narrative of what
allows it to be more successful
in the visual medium is showing
that discipline, not just telling,
showing how much they had to endure,
whether it's the cigarettes
being put out in your hair,
the hot coffee being
poured down your back,
having you friends call you names.
It was the most important
thing we could convey.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: Any other
questions from students here?
Right here.
Ma'am?
>> This question is for both
of you all, you all say a lot
about positivity, so do you guys
see similarities in today's actions
as far as protesting
you did in your day?
>> Rep. John Lewis: Well,
today, I see similarities.
The women marched just a few days, a
few weeks ago, whether in Washington
or in Atlanta, around the
nation, around the world,
people use the same
techniques and tactics.
Some of the music was a
little more upbeat, and music,
Andrew would tell you, research,
music is very, very powerful.
I said on occasion, if
it hadn't been for music,
the civil rights movement would
have been like a bird without wings.
It brought us together.
It created a sense of
family, a sense of solidarity
that we we're all in this thing
together, and sometimes when,
so during the freedom rides in 1961,
when we were arrested in Jackson,
Mississippi, we filled the city
jail, and later people kept coming.
We filled the county jail.
Then they took us to the heart
of the delta [inaudible]
state penitentiary,
and the people would say, the
guards, the jailers would say,
if you don't stop singing
those songs,
we're going to take your mattress.
And people would make up songs.
Andrew probably, and maybe
would sing one of them.
>> Andrew Aydin: So
low you can't hear me.
>> Rep. John Lewis: But today
you see people coming together
in an orderly, peaceful,
nonviolent fashion.
I was so proud.
I marched with the
people in Atlanta.
More than 63,000 people showed up.
And hundreds and thousands from
Atlanta came to Washington.
And people showed up at
the airport in an orderly,
peaceful, nonviolent fashion.
They learned they're
starting the movement.
It was very similar.
Andrew, I know you
have something to add.
[ Background Noise ]
>> Andrew Aydin: Well, I'm not going
to sing, but I think when you talk
about creating the climate,
creating the environment for change
to happen, music, pop culture, I
think in this day and age we have
to look beyond [inaudible].
They play a role.
But at the end of the day people
with conscience coming
together for a purpose.
I marched-- I'm going to blow out
you all speakers at this rate.
I marched here in DC, and I've
never seen anything quite like it.
I was at Barack Obama's
inauguration in 2009.
I staffed the Congressman that day.
I walked through the crowds.
It was peaceful, and
it was optimistic,
but the sense of revolution wasn't--
in 2009, we thought
we were finished.
Right. And that's why 2010 happened.
And that's what started this tumble,
but what happened at the march,
the women's march, what's happened
in the days and weeks since then,
it's not just about optimism,
it's about a sense of duty,
that we all recognize
maybe we didn't do as much
as we should have beforehand,
but we all say
with a collective voice,
it stops now.
We all have something to contribute,
and we all will contribute.
I think that very much
permeated that same feeling.
Maybe in the latter days,
from what I understand,
it got lost in the freedom highs
and things like that, but that sense
that we all have something to
contribute, and that we will rage
against injustice, together, is
the most powerful development
in my own life that I've ever
witnessed of our society.
And I hope you're prepared
because we need you next.
And it's not going to be easy.
I spent most of the time
making "March" being afraid,
and the Congressman telling me,
no, no, the best is yet to come.
I didn't know if we would finish it.
I didn't know if it
would be any good.
I didn't know if I would do a
good enough job honoring the
Congressman's story.
We're telling the story of all
the people whose stories needed
to be told.
And that was just one small piece,
so it's okay for you to be afraid,
but you got to be hopeful, and you
got to understand that the progress
of this country is on
your shoulders next.
And my generation,
Kojo's generation,
and the Congressman's generation,
we're doing everything we can
right now, but we need you.
[ Background Noise ]
>> Kojo Nnamdi: Anyone else?
We have time for one more question,
and needless to say there
are four hands raised.
Young man?
>> Hi. This is just for Mr. Lewis,
but what do you think was
the most important thing
that came out of the march?
>> Rep. John Lewis:
Out of the march?
>> Yes.
>> Rep. John Lewis: Well, because
of the march, because of the march,
excuse me, because of the march,
I've been talking too
much, I'm losing my voice.
>> Andrew Aydin: Drink some water.
>> Rep. John Lewis: Thank you.
I was in a committee meeting today.
I had holler a little bit.
>> Andrew Aydin: Good trouble.
>> Rep. John Lewis: I
had to preach a little.
[laughter]
>> Andrew Aydin: I got it.
>> Rep. John Lewis: Thank you.
[ Background Noise ]
The march from Selma to Montgomery
gave us the Voting Rights Act
of 1965.
It educated, it inspired so
many people to stand out,
to say to Congress, say to the
President of the United States,
we need to pass a Voting Rights Act.
Because of what happened on
Bloody Sunday, March 7th,
the President of the United States,
Lyndon Johnson, President Johnson,
came and spoke to [inaudible]
session
of the Congress and
introduced a bill.
We completed the march,
and on August 6, 1965,
the Voting Rights Act
was signed into law.
Hundreds and thousands and
millions of people were registered
to vote for the first time.
If it hadn't been for
the Voting Rights Act,
I'm not so sure President
Carter and President Clinton
and President Obama would
have been elected President.
And I probably wouldn't
be in Congress,
and many other local elected
officials, black, white, Latinos,
Asian American, wouldn't
be in the Congress,
but we still have a distance to go
because the Supreme Court almost
destroyed the Voting Rights Act two
years ago.
So we still have work to do.
>> Kojo Nnamdi: And it
rests on the shoulders
of your generation to some extent.
I'm afraid that's all
the time we have.
But thank you to Karen Jaffe
[phonetic] and the entire team here
at the Library of Congress'
Young Readers [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
Thank you to librarian of Congress,
Carla Hayden [phonetic],
get well soon.
[ Applause ]
Thank you to everybody in DC for
bringing in this wonderful audience
and for sending them home
with copies of the book.
[ Applause ]
And last but obviously not
least, thanks to Andrew Aydin
and Congressman John Lewis
for sharing their story.
[ Applause ]
I'll close with the words of
the later writer Frantz Fanon,
who wrote, "It is the role of each
generation out of relative obscurity
to discover its missions and
either fulfill it or betray it."
Go forth and fulfill your mission.
Thank you very much for being here.
[ Applause ]
And that's it.
>> Okay.
[ Background Noise ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.